the u.s job market that sizzled all  summer is cooling down in a big way the  economy added just 235 000 jobs in  august way under wall street  expectations and much lower than the  large job gains seen in july and in june  bankrate  bankrate senior economic analyst mark  hamrick says rising covet cases are  likely playing a big role  hiring in many industries dropped last  month as americans ate out less and  canceled trips people are dialing back  as this pandemic continues to rage in  new ways and this is having an impact on  the economy  the unemployment rate is now 5.2 percent  and many of those out of work americans  are losing a big monthly benefit with  the extra weekly 300 payments and the  pua payments ending tomorrow